sodann begrüße sie zur heutigen sitzung
in der wir uns mit diesem herrn hier
donald davidson beschäftigen werden
in der letzten sitzung hatten wir diesen
text von norman merken gelesen und sie
sehen dass diese donnell davidson sich
in seinem text mit der deutschen
übersetzung rationale lebewesen auf
diesen text vom letzten mal bezieht ist
also ganz gut und haben wir so eine art
von gedankengang so eine art von bezug
und wir wollen jetzt diesen text einfach
gemeinsam lesen aber bevor wir ihn lesen
sollten wir noch mal kurz uns
vergegenwärtigen was die thesen und
probleme des textes der letzten sitzung
gewesen waren
hier kann das von ihnen noch einmal kurz
wiedergeben was war das problem dieses
textes gewesen
und welche frage ging es kurz gefragt
also
[Musik]
das zwischen den unterschiedlich
seinen autoschlüssel zu einer großen
zukunft interessiert habe
welche fast ganz fertig
vielen dank da war noch die meldung
wurden sie dasselbe sagen hatten sie
sich meldet nicht okay also wir haben
hier die zwei positionen der autor des
letzten textes wäre sd card und die card
wird in diesem text kritisiert mit dem
text den wir letztes mal gelesen hatten
und jetzt ist nur die frage warum
unterwegs und wegen gesichtspunkt
kritisiert der autor des letzten textes
unseren klassiker descartes was sagt die
karts was die mir nicht gefällt
bezug auf das denken mit bezug auf die
frage ob tiere denken kann
also die karte zeigt ganz kurz ja oder
nein was sagt könnt ihre denken ganz
einfach nein richtig
und die frage ist jetzt die warum und da
gibt es viele
interpretationsmöglichkeiten das center
prägt das zu verstehen
also man kann sagen die karte die karts
sagt ja in die disco getanzt zu risiko
gitarrensoli zu den akten
was gehört dann noch einmal nach
descartes alles dazu zu diesen resources
capital welche akte des geistes wissen
sie was der diski tanz ist nah die
denkende substanzen also dieses das
denken und was gehört nach descartes
alles zu dieser disco getanzt muss
nochmal aufzählt ich hab das haben sie
die zusammenfassung bekommen ja da habe
ich glaube ich aufgeführt habe ich
zitiert
also packt valente des landes
partizipieren genau also wollen wollen
wir nicht wollen dann empfinden sind
ident praktisch und sie hatten noch 1
genau im finanz also ein bilden und
diese ganzen akt
würde man durchaus jetzt auf anhieb zu
dieser re scobee tanzszenen intuitiv
aber bei diesen empfinden da hätte man
da hatte ich zumindest meine probleme
wieso soll den empfinden können tiere
nicht empfinden wenn tiere keine disco
getanzt besitzen und nicht diese
intelligenz haben mit der sollen tiere
da nicht empfehlen können zeitliche
bindung möglich zu sein ohne diese
vorstellung von risco getan
das ist so ein problem was ich mir
gestellt hatte als ich es gelesen hatte
und was ist jetzt die antwort was ist
die antwort warum sind diese ganzen akte
nach descartes rational zur disco
getanzt zu zählen und warum können die
von tieren nicht gehabt werden diese
akte
da hat vorwärts
genau das ist schon mal richtig dies
sind nach descartes dadurch
ausgezeichnet dass sie eine einheit
haben einheit des ichs also sie sind
alle immer insofern geiste e akte als
sie mit unserem ich mit unserem
selbstbewusstsein verbunden sind es sind
alles könnte man auch sagen formen des
selbstbewusstseins letztendlichen und in
dem diese nackten zeigt sich immer einig
bezug
es ist also nicht so dass da einfach nur
ein trieb ist in mir der jetzt nach
irgendwas strebt das wäre nach descartes
nicht wollen und somit bedürfen oder
irgend sowas sein wollen ist für die
karte immer bewusstes wollen
und jetzt kann man auch in weiteren
schritt gehen dann völlig richtig ist es
hier die einheit des ich sie diese
ganzen akte auszeichnet und was sagt
jetzt merken hier noch mal dazu
wie formuliert er das was sagt er was
zeichnet nach descartes diese ganzen
akte aus geht das ganze jetzt ihr sprach
philosophisch an
ganz radikal bemüht empfindlicher
das selbstbewusstsein ist
argumentiert dagegen dass es eben durch
haben
das team
dass man das empfindungen gibt die nicht
unbedingt
also das wäre die reflexion und die
einheit des ichs und daraus würde nach
die karts so man kann folgen dass alle
diese akte eine professionelle struktur
aufweisen
eine position aale struktur aufweisen
also wie sie sagten wollen ist nicht
einfach nur gegen der trieb irgendwie
streben nach etwas ist immer wollen dass
ich will dass also da ist natürlich und
mit 2 ist auch noch mehr ich will da ist
was will ich wenn ich etwas will dann
ist es der fall dass ich das will und
diese form dass sie das setzte das sind
pro positionen denken dass wollen das
auch antreten dass ich empfinde etwas
dann bin ich mit dessen bewusst dass ich
jetzt das empfinden und das ist
natürlich wiederum nur möglich insofern
es in der einheit des selbstbewusstseins
vorkommt
da kommen wir heute drauf das wird heute
unser thema sein
wenn das alles im griff
oder hat das ist das ist
und genau das wird dann die leute die
frage sein
also wir werden das jetzt heute
behandelt die frage ist wenn jetzt
davidson merken so kritisiert wie es tut
oder sich so kritisch auseinandersetzt
in diesem text dann scheint es der
falsche sein dass ihr auf der seite von
dekade steht das ist das müssen wir
schauen wo steht davidson genau ihr hier
oder ihr hier in dieser freiheit das ist
die heutige leitfragen das schöne ist ja
dass man hier das davidson hier auf
diesen text zu sprechen kommen
dass er also in zitiert das schöne
dieser text sammlung dass sie
aufeinander aufbau dass die texte zu tun
haben und merken sagt jetzt mein
empfinden oder auch wollen muss nicht
immer natürlich auch denken das ist sehr
klar auch immer denken vor allem
natürlich denken denken ganz klar wir
würden sagen bei empfinden okay also das
ist höchst strittig empfinden und eine
position alle strukturen
das muss nicht sein ich habe hier
phänomenale ist bewusst sein
ich habe diesen wie zustand ich habe die
qual das quali und wie roth eindruck und
dann muss mir dabei nicht bewusst sein
dass das ein rot eindruck ist ganz auf
in diesem sinne eindruck das ist
phänomenal es bewusst zeit reicht
bewusst sein könnte man zu den karten
als sie empfinden das hat keine braucht
keine einheit des ichs und auch keine
proposition a list
einfach nur dieses auf gegen diese
sinnesempfindungen dieses phänomenale
bewusstsein aber bei denken könnte man
sagen ja bei denken ist es ganz klar
denken muss immer heißen denken dass
wenn ich etwas denke wenn ich denke dann
ist das ding proposition ahl verfasst da
sagt merkel auch nein überhaupt nicht
muss nicht proportional verfasst sein
das war ja ihre ihr punkte das sagt wenn
ich jetzt so instinktiv in der
hosentasche krame unter suche nach dem
schlüssel oder an der ampel stehe und
dann die ampel schaltet rum und ich gebe
gas und so dass das ist durchaus denken
aber das ist nicht jetzt hier explizit
proportional ich kam nicht in der
hosentasche
unter diesem gesichtspunkt dass ich
jetzt da ich glaube etwas finden zu
wollen sind es vor für proposition ahl
könnte uns sagen aber dennoch denken und
dadurch versucht merken jetzt eben auch
den tieren so eine form von dicken
zuzugestehen ist dann halt eine
schwächere form des denkens die karte
ist da ganz radikal gesagt entweder ist
das ganze proportional verfasst oder
nicht wenn es nicht proportional
verfasst ist dann ist es nicht denken
dann hat es nichts mit dieser rees zu
tun und das steht jetzt merken hier in
frage und donnell davidson scheint wie
sie richtig gesagt haben doch eher auf
der karte zwischen spur zu sein also
diese punkte von mir kommen etwas
kritisch zu sehen und das wollen wir
heute diskutieren also wie steht jetzt
davidson gegenüber merken und descartes
hinsichtlich der frage ob tiere denken
und bei davidson wie sie sicherlich
gesehen haben ganz am ende sagt der
witzen nationalität gibt es nur wenn
kommunikation vorhanden ist
kommunikation also wir müssen schauen
welche kommunikations begriff davidson
hier auch verwendet haben sie sonst noch
mehr kommen hier dazu was das anbelangt
also das ist jetzt praktisch die
grundsituation meckern sagt denken ohne
proposition ahlen struktur
genau und die karte und natürlich auch
empfinden das ist das denken ist eben
das entscheiden weil wir doch dazu
neigen denken sehr streng zu fassen
häufig zu sagen denken ist nur dann
denken wenn es diese dass strukturen ich
denke dass ich bin mir denken eine
position bewusst und das sagt merkel
das ist es nicht notwendig das haben wir
selbst in den allerwenigsten fällen
wir haben so eine grundlast eine basale
rationalität die uns im alltag hilft wie
in diesen genannten beispielen und genau
dieselbe rationalität haben auch tiere
die denken auch aber eben nicht
proposition so und jetzt schauen wir mal
wie davidson jetzt hier umgehen diesmal
einfach mal den text gemeinsam wenn ein
einwöchiger säugling noch eine schnecke
ist ein wichtiger säugling noch eine
schnecke ist das alles geschafft jetzt
kommt wenn der säugling lange genug am
leben bleibt wird er wahrscheinlich
aktion ahl werden was für die schnecke
nicht gilt
wenn wir wollen können wir vom säugling
von anfang an sagen dass er ein
rationales geschäft ist weil er
wahrscheinlich rational werden wird wenn
er am leben bleibt
oder weil er zu einer spezies gehört
über diese fähigkeiten verfügt auf
welche weise wir auch jeden in bezug auf
die rationalität verbleibt eine
differenz zwischen dem säugling und der
schnecke einerseits und der normalen
erwachsenen personen andererseits
okay hier ist jetzt dieses potential i
tät hier gibt es verschiedene argumente
man das ist diese klassische frage warum
sollen neugeborene kinder warum sollen
die auch personen zahlen warum sollen
die rationale geschöpfen seien de facto
sind sie es ja nicht de facto wenn wir
wenn wir säuglinge mit tieren
vergleichen werden wir feststellen dass
ich prima fazit keine intellektuellen
fähigkeiten aufweisen und dann kommt das
argument gibt es verschiedene argumente
hier aber wenn sie dann wie hier sagt
lange genug am leben bleiben dann wird
das sich dazu entwickeln also potenziell
teetz argument das hat der möglichkeit
nach sind diese ganzen rationalität
vermögen schon angelegt man kann sich
auf die dna beruf und sagt der säugling
ist so programmiert dass eben ab einem
bestimmten alter diese ganzen
fähigkeiten auftreten das ist alles im
kot gespeichert also es ist schon da ist
es halt nur potenziell und nicht aktuell
es hat ziemlich aktualisiert das ist
eine sache und dann kann man so eine art
von speziesismus wie peter singer sagen
würde vertreten sondern sagt als er
gehört ihm zur art mensch und die art
mensch ist eben rational so einfach ist
es nicht so einfach ist natürlich nicht
aber er scheint jetzt hier zu einer
differenz erst einmal raus zu gehen
jetzt lesen immer weiter die differenz
besteht darin proposition ahlen
proportionale einstellungen zu haben wie
etwa eine überzeugung einen wunsch eine
absicht und charme
dies wirft die frage auf wie man denn
sagen kann wann ein geschöpf proposition
alle einstellungen hat wir mögen uns
darin einig sein dass schnecken keine
solche einstellungen haben aber wie
steht es mit hunden oder schimpansen
stellen sie sich coco das
gorillaweibchen vor hat die vielleicht
positionen proposition alle
einstellungen also dass zustände
schnecken sicherlich nicht aber wunde
das war ja das beispiel dieser hund der
da diese diese hat diesen baum hoch will
dann könnte man darstellen der hund
glaubt dass das und in diesem das herz
kommt rein
die katze ist auf dem par das ist der
glaubensinhalte denkt inhalte gedanken
dies ist keine ganze ungarische frage
denn es stellt sich die philosophische
frage welche wie dance für die
entscheidung relevant ist wann ein
geschöpf proposition aale einstellung
hat
als hier sehen die das finden jetzt ganz
wichtig bei davidson dass er wirklich
sich mal die frage stellen welche
disziplin geht es jetzt ja eigentlich
wenn wir solche fragen behandeln
befinden wir uns auf einer empirischen
ebene oder befinden wir uns auch eine
philosophische ebene und worin
unterscheiden sich die philosophischen
fragen und die empirischen fragen
bezüglich irgendwelcher geistige akte
von tieren also es geht um die evidenz
evidenz ist dann eine übersetzung könnte
auch sagen welche gründe welche
überzeugenden gründe
es geht um eigentliche kriterien jetzt
an deren wie entscheiden können ob ein
geschäft von lebewesen proposition alle
einstellungen kann
zweiter ist einfach ein bisschen weiter
dass er noch ein bisschen rein kommen
einige lebewesen denken und überlegen
sie erwägen überprüfen verwehrt und
akzeptieren hypothesen sie handeln aus
gründen manchmal nachdem sie nachgedacht
sich konsequenz vorgestellt und
wahrscheinlichkeiten abgewogen habe sie
haben wünsche hoffnungen und hassgefühle
manchmal aus guten gründen auch irren
sie ihren berechnungen handeln wider
besseres wissen oder akzeptieren
grundsätze auf der grundlage
unangemessener evidenz jede dieser
leistungen aktivitäten handlungen oder
irrtümer reicht aus um zu zeigen dass
ein solches lebewesen ein rationales
lebewesen ist generation als lebewesen
zu sein heißt sehr professionelle
einstellung zu haben wie der
widersprüchlich absolut ungerechtfertigt
oder abwegig diese einstellung auch sein
mögen diese schlage ich vor ist die
antwort die frage lautet welche
lebewesen sind rational
ich beabsichtige natürlich nicht namen
zu nennen schon garnicht namen von
spezies oder anderen gruppen
ich werde nicht versuchen zu entscheiden
ob denn viele affen menschlicher
embryonen oder politiker rational muss
es heißen sind oder mehr noch ob das
einzige das computer daran hindert
rational zu sein ihre entstehung ist
meine frage lautet was macht lebewesen
oder wenn man so will irgendetwas
anderes rational und das jetzt wo die
philosophische frage
also es geht nicht darum konkret jetzt
irgendwelche erhalten als solche
auszeichnen
das wären empirische frage da würde
donald davidson seine kompetenzen
überschreiten
er fragt einfach nach der bedingung der
möglichkeit ein lebewesen rational zu
nennen und das ist eine philosophische
frage es gibt als ganz allgemein um
kriterien die erfüllt sein müssen damit
ein lebewesen als rational gelten kann
also es geht letztendlich um
begriffliche sachen davon ist die frage
ist unterscheiden ob jetzt dieses
individuum oder dieses lebewesen
tatsächlich rational ist das ist
empirisch frage es geht einfach darum
diese kriterien zu entwickeln wir haben
die kriterien diese bedingungen müssen
der fall sein damit ein lebewesen
rational genannt werden kann
dann muss die naturwissenschaft die
biologie geologie und was auch immer
genau nachprüfen ob dieses lebewesen
jetzt diesen kriterien genügt da muss
man experimente machen und so weiter und
so fort
aber diese kriterien mal zu definieren
das ist eine philosophische frage
genau das ist auch im vorherigen die tat
genannt stellt die philosophische frage
welche evidenz für die entscheidung
relevant ist ein geschöpf proposition
aale einstellung kann
es wäre auch wenn es mal interessantes
thema zu suchen wo kommt die philosophie
bei der frage nach den geist der tiere
ins spiel und wo die empirie also was
kann die philosophie leisten in dieser
frage und was kann sie nicht mehr
leisten wir müssen anders gefragt
empirie und philosophie zusammenwirken
interagieren um zu einem guten ergebnis
zu kommen wie sie die aufgabenteilung
aus das wären interessante frage von
essen zu man disziplin ihre grenzen
abzustecken
die proposition ahlen einstellungen
stellen ein interessantes kriterium für
rationalität da denn sie treten nur in
einem aufeinander abgestimmten ensemble
auf offensichtlich ist ein reichhaltiges
muster von überzeugungen wünschen und
absichten hinreichend von rationalität
und doch scheint es viel zu scharf zu
sein dies einen notwendigen bedingungen
zu machen
doch tatsächlich liegt die schärfe der
bedingung in der natur der
professionellen einstellung denn eine
einzige einstellung zu haben heißt
umfassende ergänzungen dazu zu haben
eine einzige überzeugung erfordert
nämlich viele überzeugungen und
überzeugung verlangen nach anderen
grundlegenden einstellungen wie
absichten wünschen und wenn ich recht
habe
nach dem geschenk der sprache dies
bedeutet nicht dass es keine grenzwerte
gibt trotzdem machte intrinsisch
holistische charakter von proposition
ahlen einstellung den unterschied ob man
einige oder keine einstellung hat
sondern dramatischen unterschied
jetzt frage ich zurück an sie was genau
meint jetzt labels mit dem holistischen
charakter von proposition ahlen
einstellungen erstmal die frage was ist
denn holistische behalten wissen sie das
ganzheitlich genau griechisch holosko
los heißt ganz altes baby zu um ein
ganzheitliches verhältnis oder ein
abhängigkeitsverhältnis solis muss heißt
wir können etwas individuelles nicht als
individuum erklären sondern müssen immer
die zusammenhänge den kontext man kann
auch sagen kontextuell kontextualisiert
wir müssen denn die umgebung immer
einbeziehen um zu verstehen um was es da
eigentlich geht so kann man es auch mit
diesen ganzen systemischen therapien
erklären es gibt jetzt in der medizin
diese ganzheitliche medizin diesen
ganzheitlichen zugang
das besagt eine krankheit die ist nicht
irgendwie immer nur an einem ort
lokalisierbar oder behandelbaren
krankheiten stehen durch das
zusammenwirken des gesamten organismus
wo also nicht nur an einem punkt was
schief laufen da stimmt das system
irgendwann ich die systemische
vorstellung und das sind auch kann man
auch solistische vorstellungen nennen
paulis muss heißt es geht um den ganzen
kontext und das ist jetzt hier auch
schon angeklungen in dieser beschreibung
das heißt nämlich eine einzige
überzeugung erfordert nämlich viel
überzeugung überzeugungen verlangen nach
anderen grundlegenden einstellungen die
absichten wünschen und wenn ich recht
habe nach dem geschenk der sprache
und auch hier sie treten nur aufeinander
abgestimmten ensemble auf
dieses ensemble ist die solistischen das
ist der politische kontext
wie kann man sich das vorstellen wie
viele treten proportionale einstellung
in einem aufeinander abgestimmten
ensemble auf können sie sich das
vorstellen
geben sie mal ein beispiel an
bei der militärs
ja so könnte man sich vorstellen könnte
aber auch zu es geht in die richtige
richtung
man könnte aber auch sagen der wollten
muss um die überzeugung zu haben dass
die katze den baum hoch ist oder auf dem
baum ist muss er die überzeugung haben
dass sie nicht nach rechts gerannt ist
nicht nach links gerannt ist
es geht um implikation verhältnisse
diese überzeugung die proposition steht
nicht nur für sich sondern sie ist immer
im größeren kontext eingebunden sie kann
auch eine folgerung sein sie kann eine
folgerung beziehung eingehen
sie kann letztendlich den charakter
eines schlosses haben ich komme zu der
position weil ich verschiedene andere
positionen auch noch vor augen habe und
diese position dass die katze jetzt da
auf dem baum ist die folgt aus den
anderen proposition es geht um logische
für abhängigkeit verhältnisse eine
konklusion zum beispiel konklusion von
rationalen argumentation ist ein auch
proposition das volk dann auch bestimmte
missen und prämissen sind auch
proposition sie sehen es gibt also
folgerung verhältnisse
so könnte man sich vorstellen als dass
man sagt der hund hat zwar diese
proposition aale einstellung die katze
ist auf dem baum
aber er hat sie nicht nur als solche
isoliert sind
er hat sie gewonnen durch einen schluss
vielleicht sogar einen logischen schluss
aus verschiedenen prämisse heraus
verschieden anderen beobachten sie kann
nicht recht sein
da ist ein hindernis das eine mauer also
es ist der fall dass sie da nicht hin
ist weil das ist und daraus folgt dann
das sie da hoch ist so könnte man es zum
beispiel also eine position ist in den
seltensten absichten wirklich nur für
sich stehen
das meint er mit diesem intrinsisch
solistischen charakter und überzeugungen
auch das letzte mal weiter diesen
unterschied zu stark zu machen und ihn
von der sprache abhängig zu machen ruft
den vorwurf des anthropozän tourismus
auf den plan der vorwurf ist berechtigt
aber es sollte nicht gegen mich erhoben
werden ich beschreibe lediglich ein
merkmal bestimmter begriffe trotz allem
ist es nicht überraschend dass unsere
menschliche sprache überreiche
ressourcen verfügt um männer und frauen
von anderen geschöpfen zu unterscheiden
genau ich meine von den inuit sagt dass
sie bei einem wortschatz verfügen der
sie der laut verschiedene arten von
schnee auszumachen
das heute freilich als ein mythos gilt
wir geben mit unserer sprache anlass
dazu dies und damit auch uns selbst als
etwas besonderes erscheinen zu lassen
was ist jetzt hier das problem
worin besteht jetzt hier der ermöglicht
die möglichkeit des anthropozän
tourismus
unter allen menschen verteidigt
um diese weise
genau die frage ist also die gibt es
einen neutralen punkt von dem aus wir
als menschen die tiere objektiv
beschreiben können da können wir uns
können wir uns aus unserer menschlichen
haut heraus reflektieren an einen
neutralen punkt von dem aus wir dann
objektiv tiere beschreiben können das
ist die frage ist haben wir auch ganz zu
beginn des seminars behandelt
anthropozän tourismus wäre es wie sie
noch mal was der gegenbegriff oder so
ein antrag begriff in diesem kontext war
ja genau andere prozent riss muss heißt
wir stellen uns ins zentrum und deswegen
verlieren wir den blick auf gewisse
feinheiten oder gewisse phänomene
gewisse eigenschaften von tieren die
interessant werden und anthropomorphe
musste gegen tendenz aber letztendlich
in demselben problem gewitzelt dass wir
immer nur auf uns bezogen sind
anthropozän tristan trip home office
muss heißt wir stülpen unser denken den
tieren über wir wir projizieren in die
tiere gewisse eigenschaften hinein die
da nicht sind aber letztendlich ist die
wurzel der selbe wir beziehen uns
eigentlich nur auf uns wir beziehen wir
uns so auf uns dass wir den tieren gar
nicht zu sprechen
oder wir beziehen und so auf uns das
zementieren mcsim von alles zu schreiben
was in uns ist aber wir sind
letztendlich darin beide mal in uns
selbst gefangen
das ist so dieses problem wir kommen aus
unserer haut nicht heraus und die frage
eben die sich stellt ist auch die
philosophische frage im kontext dieser
tier mensch problematik wie können wir
einen adäquaten eine adäquate
einstellung gegenüber den tieren
entwickeln etablieren
die
diesen problemen von antrup home office
muss und anderen prozent riss muss
entgeht im märz vor dem hintergrund der
problematik dass wir eben auch wenn wir
denken immer menschen sind die denken
das ist die frage wie können wir dieses
verhältnis objektivieren so gut wie
möglich objektivieren das ist ja die
apps theologische frage die es da im
hintergrund gibt man genau diese diese
inuit sache das ist diese sprachliche
realität oder relativität diese live
hypothese kennen sie die viva delhi mit
2 das ist diese these in den 50ern und
60ern sehr früh geäußerte these dass
eben die sprache
je nach lebensweltlichen kontext eine
gewisse differenzierungs fähigkeit
aufweist die hochgradig verschieden sein
kann zum anderen lebensweltlichen
kontexten dass man eben sagt also
menschen die eben in einer sehr
schneereichen gegend wohnen die haben
eben einen begriff von schnee der
unglaublich differenziert ist man kann
eben zehn form von schnee und layout
vorschläge unterscheiden wir hier können
vielleicht nur eine art oder zwei arten
unterscheiden
dafür können wir vielleicht irgendwelche
anderen natürlichen vorkommnisse die von
sitter behandeln darauf bezieht sich der
witzen hier
ja die zweite ich habe versprochen dass
ich nicht die frage diskutieren werde ob
besondere spezies rational sind
es wird aber unmöglich sein den anschein
zu vermeiden dass ich über die großen
leistungen fähig keine tiere spreche
weil sich ein großer teil der diskussion
über die natur des denkens teilweise auf
die geistige vermögen von nicht
menschlichen lebewesen konzentriert hat
ich betrachte diesen zugang einfach als
eine schillernde und manchmal
emotionsgeladene art und weise über die
natur des denkens nachzudenken
ok geht's einfach nur das denken entgeht
sich um das denken der menschen sondern
um das denken grundsätzen das denken von
lebewesen und jetzt kommt der bezug zu
unserem auto des letzten textes mahnmal
komme erzählt folgende geschichte die
zeigen soll dass 100 denken jetzt
zitierte ihn nehmen wir einmal an unser
hund jagt die nachbarskatze sie rast mit
volldampf auf eine eiche zu schwenkt
aber im letzten moment plötzlich ab und
verschwindet auf einem nahen ahorn der
hund zieht dieses manöver nicht und
stellt sich bei der herangekommen auf
die hinterbeine kratzt mit den pfoten am
stamm als wolle er hochklettern und bild
aufgeregt zu den ersten hoch wir die wir
die episode vom fenster aus beobachten
der neutrale beobachter sozusagen von
oben sagen er denkt der hund die katze
sei die arche hochgeklettert und das ist
die frage denkt der hund das wirklich
vollkommen fügte noch hinzu wir würden
sagen der hund bella im falschen baum
hoch behauptet dass unter den gegebenen
umständen jemand der dem hund diese
überzeugung zu schreiben hatte die
überzeugung dass die katze auf den
bereichen ist sehr wohl recht haben
könnte ja fast sicher recht hätte hätte
genau die art von evidenz die
erforderlich sei um eine solche
zuschreibung zu rechtfertigen ich möchte
ein vorläufiges argument vorbringen was
man kann's behauptung zweifel ziehen
soll
es ist klar dass die evidenz für die
überzeugung des hundes davon abhängt
dass man überzeugung als einen
determinieren faktor für eine handlung
und eine emotionale reaktion auf fast
wir werden nämlich dazu aufgefordert aus
dem was wir säen abzuleiten dass der
hund die katze fangen will dass er
aufgrund dieses wunsches und eine
überzeugung darüber wo die katze hin
genau verlaufen ist an einem bestimmten
ort rennt und dass er seiner frustration
nicht imstande zu sein die katze auf dem
baum zu folgen freien lauf lässt indem
er geld muss es heißen am boden start
die details müssen natürlich nicht
richtig sein aber der punkt ist soweit
klar wenn wir berechtigt sind auf
überzeugungen zu schließen sind wir auch
berechtigt auf absichten und wünsche und
vielleicht noch auf viele
vielmehr zu schließen
was sagt es davidson dazu wie verhält
sich jetzt der ewigen zudem zu einem
argument bei merken was sagt er also
möchte jedenfalls sagt er hier
ich möchte ein vorläufiges argument
vorbringen dass merkels behauptung in
zweifel ziehen soll
verletzlich kritisch dazu es ist klar
dass die evidenz für die überzeugung des
bundes davon abhängt dass man die
überzeugung als einen der terminierung
faktor für eine handlung und eine
emotionale reaktion auf fast dass der
hund die katze fangen will das ein
wunsch hatte auch
in dem das muss allen heißen also in dem
diese ganzen begründenden konjunktionen
sehr konjunktionen sie sehen also hier
geht es um
es geht hier praktisch um ein kontext es
geht hier nicht allein um den glauben
des hundes dass die katze hier auf dem
baum ist sondern es geht um eine
holistische system könnte man sagen von
mit bedingungen
auch noch entscheiden die sie abzuleiten
es gibt mir mehr schließen also auf
diese position des hundes auf grund
dem und so weiter
es gibt diese position des hundes die
wir ihm unterstellen die steht nicht
einfach nur so da sind die ist im
kontext von anderen positionen von
anderen ab leitungs verhältnissen und
das meint das ballistische bei davidson
die proposition ist nicht ganz alleine
isoliert vorhanden
doch wie steht es mit der angeblichen
überzeugung des bundestags die katze die
eigentliche hochgeklettert zeit diese
eiche ist zufällig der älteste baum in
sichtweite denkt der hund dass die katze
dem ältesten baum in sichtweite
hochgeklettert seien oder dass die katze
denselben baum hochräder zwei wie
letztes mal als der hund sie gejagt hat
es fällt schwer diesen fragen einen sinn
zu geben
dann scheint es aber nicht möglich zu
sein zwischen ziemlich verschiedenen
dingen zu unterscheiden von denen man
sagen könnte dass der hund sie glaube
was jetzt hier das problem
also mal konnten den modellen bis 15
andere profis muss genau als ist es
zumindest unklar was der hund also dass
der hund eine eindeutige position haben
kann
es ist möglich dass er verschiedenes
unter einer ähnlichen position denkt
gerade bezug auf dem baum ist es
derselbe baum wie das letzte mal ist es
dieser baum ist es der älteste baum und
so weiter als ist es völlig unbestimmt
kein
unterstellen
könnte höchstens sagen dass eben die
tatsache dass der hund also es geht um
die frage wie wir über den hund in
dieser situation reden und wir hatten
sie jetzt merken gelesen hatten sie ihn
als ich hatte ihn wir hatten ja so
gelesen dass er offensichtlich nicht der
auffassung ist dass wir diesen starken
proportionalen begriff brauchen zu
denken
wie könnte dann merken sich den hund
vorstellen vor der reiche
das wasserfest schnitt davon nichts mit
so wie in der hosentasche irgendwie noch
was tun kann ja genau also und die frage
jetzt wie man das internet
davidson scheint so ein bisschen richten
wie sie richtig sagen merkel zu
unterstellen dass er glaube dass der
hund eine professionelle einstellung
arzt ein bisschen geld
die zeit oder nicht nur opposition alles
einstellen genau richtig knapp aber hier
scheint jedenfalls der witzen doch
starke ließ art von denken voraus sitzen
ja ich glaube die gute bemerkungen ja
wenn ich will meinen titel
diese runde
bedenklich auch nicht auch dieses jahr
will offensichtlich sagen dass man
diesen baum dass zu diesen baum nicht
gibt eigentlich sondern das eben immer
die frage sein muss in welchem kontext
kommt wieder dieser baum vor
ich lese so dass davidson auf diesen
holistischen zusammenhang hinweisen
möchte also baum ist nicht der baum zu
baum steht wiederum kontext von anderen
positionen
genau also sie sagen praktisch es ist
unerheblich
sie würden jetzt sagen diese diese
dieser einwand von davidson oder diese
bemerkung es unerheblich weil der hund
sich nicht fragt was von baumes ist und
es ist der baum wo die katze hoch ist
dann ist es völlig irrelevant
doch noch fiel
das
nicht jeder
ja wir lesen einfach mal weiter
hier wird es schwierig zehnter mit
interpretation er sagt eine art und
weise anzugeben dass wir eine
proportionale einstellung zu schreiben
ist folgende wir stellen fest dass die
sätze die wir für die zuschreibung
verwenden von waren zur falschen setzen
werden können bei den wörtern die die
entgegen stand der einstellung
herausgreifen einen referierenden
ausdruck durch einen anderen ersetzen
der auf kasse bedienen referiert die
überzeugung dass die katze das alte hoch
geklettert sei ist nicht die gleiche
überzeugung wie jene dass die katze den
ältesten baum in sichtweite hochklettern
2 wenn wir wörter wie glauben denken und
beabsichtigen verwenden da war aber das
merkmal des semantischen
undurchsichtigkeit weglassen stellt sich
die frage ob wir diese wörter verwenden
um proposition alle einstellungen
zuzuschreiben
man hat nämlich schon vor langem erkannt
das semantische undurchsichtigkeit das
reden überproportionale einstellungen
vom reden über andere dinge
unterscheidet
was ist jetzt hier gemeint können sie
wie verstehen sie jetzt dieses zitat
[Musik]
also hier geht es offensichtlich um
referenz es geht jetzt also um das
verhältnis von sinn und bedeutung als es
die seele zielt dezidiert geht es hier
um sprach philosophische
unterscheidungen also wir können jetzt
den baum unterscheiden als baum als
physikalisches objekt das ist die eiche
hier und wir können aber mit
verschiedenen ausdrücken verschiedenen
intentionen als intention intentional
können wir auf denselben mit
verschiedenen sinnen auch letztendlich
können wir auf denselben gegenstand
referieren die eiche kann in einem
bestimmten kontext geben die älteste
baum in sichtweite seien
wo du sie kann irgendwas anderes sein
den sinn es ist aber immer dasselbe
objekt ja genau genau extension und
intention beiträge also die venus ist
sowohl das ist das objekt die venus ist
dieses fest dieses szenario objekt ein
gegenstand und wir können uns in
verschiedenen hinsichten auf diesen
gegenstand beziehen
wir können sagen es ist der morgenstern
was sagt dieser gegenstand wenn er
morgens am schnellsten leuchtet und wir
können aber denselben gegenstand auch in
anderen sind sprechen nämlich sagen es
der abendstern ist der stern der am
hellsten am abend leuchtet wir haben
also verschiedene sinne aber dieselben
denselben bezug dieselbe referenzen und
so kann es auch sein wenn wir über den
baum reden also die venus wir setzen
jetzt einfach durch diese euch
das könnte man die semantische
undurchsichtigkeit nennen lesen mal
weiter jemand könnte nun vorschlagen
dass die stelle die im satz der hund
denkt dass die katze die hochkippe 2
durch den ausdruck die eiche eingenommen
wird durchsichtig und kleins technologie
es sei also kein anderer sprachphilosoph
diese zeit
die richtige art überzeugung des hundes
auszudrücken so geht der vorschlag
weiter lautet der hund denken bezug auf
diese eiche dass die katze an ihr hoch
geklettert sei oder diese eiche ist jene
von der der hund denkt dass die katze an
ihr hoch geklettert sein muss es heißen
solche konstruktion mögen zwar
denjenigen der die zuschreibung vornimmt
von der verpflichtung befreien eine
beschreibung für den gegenstand zu geben
die derjenige mit der überzeugung
akzeptieren würde sie implizieren aber
dennoch dass es eine solche beschreibung
gibt die die beschreibung also die sache
die beschreibung über die sache in der
asse ist die sache greift einen
gegenstand heraus den derjenige mit der
überzeugung irgendwie heraus greifen
könnte mit einer verbreiteten wenn auch
irreführenden redeweise könnte man sagen
der hund muss glauben und zwar unter
einer bestimmten beschreibung des baumes
dass die katze diesen baum hoch
geklettert sei aber welche art von
beschreibung würde vertrauen passen
kern der hund beispielsweise von einem
gegenstand glauben dass ein baum ist
dies erscheint unmöglich es sei denn in
dem andere hund habe zahlreiche
allgemeine überzeugung von bäumen
dass sie dinge sind die wachsen dass sie
erde und wasser brauchen dass die
blätter oder nadeln haben dass sie
brennen
es gibt keine feststehende liste von
dingen die jemand glauben muss der ein
begriff von einem baum hat aber ohne
viele allgemeine überzeugung gäbe es
kein grund um eine überzeugung also bei
einer überzeugung in bezug auf ein baum
nach weniger in bezug auf die zu
identifizieren
ähnliche erwägungen gelten dafür was der
hund angeblich über die katze denn was
ist jetzt hier das argument
ja
würden sie den namen norton bisschen
gestiegen
richtig ja also die frage ist die wm
jetzt die kven der hund jetzt denkt
proposition aldi katze ist den baum hoch
dann sagt jetzt davidson dann müsste sie
wenn sie wirklich denkt dann müsste sie
einen begriff von baum haben
man müsste sie letztendlich und das ist
jetzt das holistische müsste sie
impliziert auch noch an diese ganzen
anderen dinge denken oder überzeugungen
haben im plakativer verhältnis also dass
praktisch bäume brennen können dass die
blätter oder nadeln haben und so weiter
die müsste sie glauben um einen begriff
von ein baum zu haben
ist es notwendig muss man diese ganzen
überzeugung haben um einen begriff vom
baum zu haben sie noch mal kurz
ok genau genau ok also müsste man das
was sie wollten auch noch sein
unter
erkennen sie eine kühlbox
das ist ein ding gemacht
ich weiß es nicht genau
irgendwann beginnt es welt
yahoo
zusätzlichen grip setzen
das wäre eine möglichkeit aber eine
andere möglichkeit die noch einfacher
wäre wäre glaube ich wie sie sagen
einfach zu sagen und geht sich um den
baum um und geht es darum dass die katze
da ist dieses index kalisch
richtig dann werden wir wieder etwas
bemerken das ist richtig
dann würde man eben sagen es geht gar
nicht direkt um eine position aale
einstellung oder um den begriff das geht
so wie wir in die hosentasche eben
fassen um einen schlüssel zu finden eben
um dieses situativ direkt verfügbare
objekte und uns es geht eigentlich nur
darum dass da ein objekt ist das geht
nicht darum was für ein objekt das ist
halt ein objekt da ist ein gegenstand
hören
das war ihr punkt so ein bisschen hier
zu finden
zur erinnerung
also sie würden dann mit sagen dann
implizit dann das davidson doch ein zu
strengen begriff von begriff hat
und das ist um ein begriff zu sein
weitere überzeugung impliziert der
begriff muss weitere überzeugung
implizieren
die damit einhergehen diesem
holistischen sinn
also er würde eben sagen der hund hat
keinen begriff von baum wo jetzt die
frage was folgt daraus
vermerken folgt daraus nicht dass der
und nicht denkt vormerken folgt daraus
dass der hund dennoch denken kann in
einem schwächeren sinne von denken so
wie wir eben diese beispiele genannt
haben und jetzt wollen wir uns vor allem
was folgt daraus folgt für davidson
jetzt heraus dass der hund anhalt in
schwächeren sinne denkt oder ist jetzt
davidson nicht doch so sind in der
tendenz hier auf die karte zurück zu
gehen
also könnte es sein dass davidson sagt
also wir müssen jetzt nicht so ein
risiko geht ans oder so so eine einheit
des selbstbewusstseins voraussetzen aber
vielleicht könnte jetzt davidson sagen
nach dem was er bisher gelesen haben es
muss unrealistisches beziehungsgeflecht
von begriffen geben also nicht die
einheit des selbstbewusstseins sondern
die einheit der implikationen der
begriffe die einheit von überzeugungen
und begriffen von anderen proposition
ahlen einstellungen die damit in
zusammenhang stehen
und wenn wir nicht diesen holistischen
kontext oder diese aura könnte man auch
sagen dieses begriffs aura die an jedem
begriff aufscheint die ganzen volkes
beziehungen zu anderen begriffen wenn
diese aura nicht da ist diese
holistische begrifflichkeit dann haben
wir es nicht mit dingen zu tun das wäre
eine möglichkeit nach dem was wir bis
jetzt gelesen haben
auch dass das nur ein mensch
ja also wir müssen
ich bin nur den namen des kunden wird
und die kumpel
ja aber ich denke dennoch müsste es
logisch kommunizierbar sein das müsste
die grundbedingung sondern müssten dann
transformieren können zwischen unseren
ameisen zwischen uns enorm heißen es
müsste eben auch zu uns kommunizierbar
sein
das ist eben wieder jetzt die
philosophische frage wir können
natürlich immer annehmen dass da auch
begriffe sind haben wir müssen dann
kriterien angeben um es möglicherweise
verifizieren zu können das ist also die
aufgabe die sich uns nach davidson ich
glaube zu recht stellt können sicherlich
auch davon ausgehen dass bestimmte auch
niedrigere lebensform verstrichen
niedrigere ameisen jetzt zum beispiel
dass die begriffe müssen zugleich ein
kriterium dafür angeben wie wir es
verifizieren können
ja aber dann wäre es ebenso dann kann
ich auch sagen der stein könnte auch
denken
ich kann zwar kann halt nur nicht in ihn
hinein sehen und das ist dann so ein
bisschen das problem der das prinzip wie
wir es am anfang hatten der
ontologischen sparsamkeit und ich glaube
das hat was für sich wir sollten wenn
wir nicht wirklich möglichst objektive
kriterien entwickeln kann ihre sinnvolle
kriterien entwickeln können nachdem wir
bestimmen können entscheiden können ob
begrifflichkeit vorliegt wenn wir das
nicht können dann sollten wir davon
ausgehen dass dort keine kognitiven
leistung vorhanden sind
ich glaube dass das durchaus was für
sich hat das schreiben zumindest perler
und wild in ihrer einleitung in diesen
weg in diesen suhrkamp band hat
schreiben die das nun und davids und
machte darauf aufmerksam dass wir als
philosophen immer kriterien entwickeln
müssen bedingungen angeben müssen die
erfüllt sein müssen um diese
eigenschaften zu unterstellen die
konkreten nachweis zu erbringen die
konkreten empirischen belege zu liefern
das ist dann jenseits unserer kompetenz
das müssen dann wie ich sagte so logan
oder biologen machen
wir müssen wenigstens die bedingungen
der möglichkeit angeben die kriterien
die erfüllt sein müssen damit eben das
dann zugeschrieben werden kann so was
wie ein geist und so als ist jahren
alles offen
die welt zu sehen
er würde es nicht sagen er würde sagen
ich glaube ich nicht
ich glaube nicht dass davidson das sagen
möchte ich glaube der witze zieht sich
zurück auf eine aus seiner sicht trans
humanen perspektive es sagt es geht
einfach um beziehungen von begriffen
es geht um begriffs komplexität die muss
nicht menschlich sein
die griffe könnten auch tiere haben aber
es muss ein bestimmtes verhältnis von
begrifflichkeit vorliegende komplexität
von begriffs verhältnissen wenn die
nicht da ist also wenn die implikation
damit nicht einher gehen diese diese
aura wie ich es jetzt mit der foris
genannt habe dann können wir nicht davon
ausgehen dass vielleicht sogar überhaupt
ein begriff von begriffe sind immer der
in kontexten von überzeugungen von
anderen positionen vorhanden und nie
allein für sich genommen so
interpretiert davids ganz hinten noch
einmal ja
die sprache
lesen
sprachen
ein
also man kann durchaus sagen dass man
jetzt sprache nicht so eng fassen muss
dass man sprach weiter fassen kann
einmal muss halt immer bedenken dass
sprache durchaus von durch semantik und
syntax und vielleicht auch pragmatik
eben gekennzeichnet ist also es geht
einmal darum das zeigt eine bestimmte
bedeutung bekommt durch seine
regelhaftigkeit der verwendung und dann
geht es aber auch darum dass wir je
nachdem wie wir die zeichen kombinieren
neben und anderen sinn bekommen wenn das
der fall wäre dann kann man da durchaus
drüber reden also es halt immer die
frage jetzt wieder unser geschäft als
philosophen wir versuchen jetzt wäre ein
begriff von sprache zu entwickeln der
sprache nicht zu weit fasst weil sonst
kann halt jedes zeichensystem als
sprache bezeichnet werden wenn wir das
gleich wenn wir das spezifische von
sprache wirklich bewahren wollen und
sich inflationär verwenden wollen den
begriff dann müssen wir hier kriterien
angeben die erfüllt sein müssen
unabhängig jetzt von der frage ob sie
tatsächlich erfüllt sind das müssen wir
dann empirisch bestätigen da wäre
durchaus so was wie eine semantik also
dass bedeutung durch zeichen entsteht
und dass diese bedeutung eben auch eine
so eine syntaktische struktur hat das
also durch die kombination von zeichen
neu bedeutung auf eine sehr flexible
weise generiert werden kann das sagt
eckhard zb und dann könnte man
nachschauen ob das bei pferden so ist
das 10 mp rische frage
den 3
genau
eine baustelle
auch zum beispiel aufgrund
wieso
wir spielen alles ist herrn haben schon
aufpassen
das ist ein gutes beispiel also spielen
wenn wenn tiere spiel dann ist das immer
ein sehr gutes zeichen weil das dann
diese flexibilität anzeiger von der e
card auch gesprochen hatte brauchen
diese freiheit in der kombination von
zeichen und wenn hinreichend komplexe
flexibilität von zeichen haben verzeigen
verwendung dann denke ich sind wir nach
einem engeren begriff ansprache
berechtigt sie anzunehmen
das muss man eben empirisch dann zeigen
aber zunächst sollte man eben durchaus
sprache möglichst eng fassen um nicht
dann irgendwie jeder form von
kommunikation sprachlich kite zu
unterstellen
also wirklich immer überlegen was
zeichnet sprache aus dass man täglich
syntax also eine ordnungsstrukturen
flexibilität im zeichen einsatz dass man
zum beispiel auch mit möglichst wenig
zeichen möglichst viele bedeutung
bedeutung erreichen kann ein möglichst
geringes arsenal ein zeichen unser
alphabet zb was eben durch kombination
unendlich viele bedeutung generieren
kann
wer seine möglichkeiten okay wie ich
glaube das hatten wir jetzt gelesen also
hier geht es jetzt um diese begriffliche
struktur wir identifizieren gedanken
unterscheiden zwischen ihn und
beschreiben sie als das was sie sind da
sie nur in einem engmaschigen netz von
miteinander verbundenen überzeugungen
lokalisiert werden können wenn wir einem
hund wirklich auch verständlicherweise
einzelne überzeugungen zuschneiden
können müssen wir im stande sein uns
vorzustellen wie wir entscheiden würden
ob der hund viele andere überzeugung von
jener art hat die notwendig sind um den
ersten überzeugung einen sinn zu geben
ganz gleichgültig wo wir beginnen mir
muss es heißen mir scheint dass wir bald
bei einer art von überzeugungen ankommen
von denen wir überhaupt nicht wissen wie
wir von ihnen sagen können ob ein hund
sie hat jedoch gleichzeitig solcher art
sind das unsere erste zuversichtliche
zuschreibung ohne sie zweifelhaft
erscheint
das sagte jetzt hier
der pkws erkennen wenn sich das auch
umsetzen die karten und nicht über diese
abbiegen
[Musik]
oder wir müssen zumindest können also
ist es wieder diese philosophische
reflexion was ist die bedingung der
möglichkeit von tierischer sprache wir
müssten eben die überzeugung angeben
können
die notwendig sind um den anderen
überzeugen einen sinn zu geben
es geht letztendlich wieder um diesen
hollis muss eine überzeugung die
proposition steht nie nach davidson
alleine für sich sind immer in einem
verbindungs geflecht das kann über
begründungen laufen folgen
einschränkungen randbedingungen von
anderen überzeugungen diese aura visits
genannt hatte
die muss man auch sagt davidson angeben
können
alle holistische begriffs realistischen
begriffs auffassung er sagt das ist ein
engmaschiges netz engmaschiges netz
miteinander verbunden überzeugung
und jetzt geht es um das kriterium wie
können wir entscheiden ob der und viele
andere überzeugungen hat die notwendig
sind
hat hier sehen sie das ist jetzt die
philosophische ist die wir müssen ein
engmaschiges netz an nehmen können von
überzeugung damit der hund gedanken
haben kann
das ist jetzt so diese dieses kriterium
das philosophische kriterium was
davidson jetzt hier entwickelt ja nicht
nur verlangt jede überzeugung eine ganze
welt von weiteren überzeugungen von dir
ein inhalt und eine identität gegeben
wird sondern die besonderheit jeder
anderen position ahlen einstellungen
hängt auch von einer ähnlichen wild von
überzeugungen ab um die überzeugung zu
haben dass die katze die eiche
hochgeklettert muss sich zahlreiche ware
überzeugung in bezug auf katzen und
bäume haben von dieser katze und diesen
baum dem ort der äußeren erscheinung den
gewohnheiten von katzen und bäume und so
weiter aber das gleiche gilt wenn ich
mich frage ob die katze die arche hoch
geklettert sei wenn ich befürchte dass
sie es getan hat wenn ich hoffe dass sie
es getan hat und ich wünsche dass sie es
getan hat oder wenn ich beabsichtige sie
dazu zu bringen überzeugung vor allem
ware überzeugungen spielen unter den
proposition ahlen zuständen eine
zentrale rolle
daher möchte ich von allen positionen zu
stünden als gedanken sprechen
also was wird hier wieder ausgesagt
letztendlich
letztendlich letztendlich schon genau
es ist hier eben nochmal terrorismus
eine sieht man es da schon eine welt von
weiteren überzeugung jeder überzeugung
vielleicht eine welt von weiteren
überzeugung
also das ist auch ich weiß nicht ob sie
haben sie mal von robert bränden gehört
brender dieser pitts bürger der
hägeraner der hat diesen begriff des in
francis muss prägt in valencia liz muss
heißt es geht immer um folgerung
beziehungen differenz ist diese
folgerung schulterschluss als um eine
bedeutung zu bekommen um zur bedeutung
kommen wir immer nur über schlüsse
es geht darum dass wir aus einem
holistischen kontext die richtigen
folgerungen beziehungen explizit machen
in valencia liz muss ganz grob gesagt
und donner davidson ist ein bisschen
älter ist ja auch schon verstorben aber
der scheint mir in dieselbe kerbe
geschlagen wie robert bränden die das
dann mit hegel und anderen neueren
denken macht hegel ist insofern
interessant als bei hegel auch alles
miteinander zusammenhängt
hägele ist einer der größten posten oder
holistic oder wie man ihn nennt
holistisch orientierten philosophen bei
hegel hängt alles mit allem zusammen und
irgendwie willkürlich sind ganz bestimmt
auf eine bestimmte weise
und das kann man jetzt auch sprach
philosophisch so interpretieren dass
alles eine folgerung beziehung haben
muss dass alle überzeugung von jede
überzeugung von anderen überzeugen auf
eine ganz bestimmte logischerweise
abhängt
das ist das nicht der hund die katze
nicht das ist okay wenn wir sagen der
hund zieht die katze dann haben wir die
überzeugung dass der hund die katze
sieht es geht also um den positionen
gehalt wenn der hund selbst die katze
sieht dann
ist die frage ob überzeugung braucht man
kann zum beispiel sagen der hund zieht
nur dann die katze wenn er sagen könnte
oder denken könnte ich sehe dass da eine
katze ist ja aber ich denke durchaus da
bin ich auch auf der seite von merken
dass ein hund nicht proposition aale
einstellung zu haben braucht um eine
katze wahrzunehmen oder so also dass er
da irgendwie was registriert da da läuft
irgendwas und der jagdinstinkt wird
aktiviert
ich glaube nicht dass 100 zur
proposition einstellung irgendwie
vorhanden haben muss oder so aber hier
geht es ja darum um die überzeugung zu
haben dass die katze die eiche hoch
geklettert sei also der hund musste
überzeugung haben er muss nicht einfach
nur sehen dass die katze die eigentlich
hoch dotiert ist es und er muss das
bewerten er muss also das sind so eine
art von proposition ahler struktur
bringt und das zu können sagt jetzt
davidson muss er zahlreiche ware
überzeugen bezug auf katzen boden haben
also es geht um diesen diesen ganzen
kontext diese aura die dann plötzlich
auf scheint wenn wir mal von einem
einzelnen einzelne überzeugung reden
das gleiche gilt wenn ich mich frage
also es geht jetzt auch für uns menschen
ob die katze hoch geklettert sei wenn
ich befürchte dass sie es getan hat wenn
ich hoffe dass sie es getan wenn ich
wünsche usw
also da hängen immer andere überzeugen
noch mit zusammen ok bringt es als
bringt jetzt proposition aale
einstellung mit überzeugungen in
verbindung mit überzeugung werden häufig
so unter den tisch gekehrt
man sieht jetzt nur die proposition oder
man denkt nur über die proposition nach
das iks und vergisst dass jede position
zahlreiche überzeugung im schlepptau hat
ich komme davon nicht loslösen ja
sie erklärten das leben
eine völlig berechtigte rückfragen an
davidson genau genau wie erklären wir es
uns dann wenn wir nicht ohne dass wir
jetzt solche überzeugungen oder
präpositionen unterstellen weil david
und zumindest was jetzt gesagt hat ihr
skeptisch zu sein scheint so was dem und
zuzustimmen
wie kann er dann diesen zustand so
erklären dass es sinn macht ihr könnt
natürlich ganz einfach sagen dieser
zustand macht keinen sinn
dieser zustand ist sinnlos sie können
nicht verstehen aber das wäre etwas
contento tief
rechneten
sind
wäre möglich oder könnte sagen hat home
office muss wir projizieren irgendwas
ein hund hinein
das ist die einzige mögliche erklärung
könnte er sein antrieb home office muss
sagt er jetzt nicht aber
er müsste halt er müsste so
argumentieren wie die kommilitonen ist
getan hat sagen gut da wurde scheint mir
da ist ein instinkt aktiviert worden ja
einfach auf diese dieser mechanistischen
ebene müsste er dann wenn er ist jetzt
tot ist oder jetzt hier nicht immer
ich glaube ich jetzt sofort gesagt ist
das einfach diese reaktionskette
unterbrochen das versorgen bereits
ziemlich hundes und dann er hatte
irgendwie einen reit verpasst
bereicherten bekommen die muss man das
ganze ab
genau computers computer cd spieler
bleibt hängen
sie kennen das alle wenn das lied dann
immer wieder so die fünf ersten fünf
sekunden wieder wiedergibt ist die
platte dreht er sozial nicht jetzt in
diesem text zumindest bis morgen gelesen
haben aber so könnte man es eben sagen
da ist einfach so dass der hund der weiß
hat keine informationen mehr ist am ende
angekommen er hört eben darauf wurde
seine letzte aktivität noch sinnvoll war
und ob dort einfach
dann könnte man es sagen systemfehler
oder so
nicht abgestürzt aber irgendwie
herabstürzen heißt hier der computer
macht gar nichts mehr so aber er macht
ihr noch was der hunde
dann denkt okay das ist jetzt ok richtig
ja dann ist die platte die richtige
rolle wiedergefunden worden soll das
programm kann weiter operieren sind das
programm kann wieder anspringen
sozusagen es ist wieder aktiviert worden
sie sollen ja ja so richtig man müsste
es dann in dieser sprache eben
beschreiben wie ich oben bemerkt habe
gibt es vielleicht keine feststehende
liste von überzeugung von denen ein
bestimmter gedanke abhängt trotzdem sind
viele wahre überzeugung notwendig alle
der erforderlichen überzeugung sind
allgemein aber wahrscheinlich bearish
wird für die überzeugung dass katzen
kratzen oder an ihnen hochklettern
können andere überzeugung sind auf einen
besonderen einzelfall bezogen etwa dass
die katze die wir vor allem momentanen
vorbeirennen sehen aber noch in der
umgebung ist wieder andere überzeugung
sind logisch gedanken haben genau wie
proposition logische relationen da die
identität eines gedankens nicht von
seinem platz in einem logischen netz
andere gedanken geschieden werden kann
lässt er sich in diesem netz nicht
anderswohin setzen ohne dass er ein
anderer gedanke wird eine radikale
inkohärenz von überzeugung ist daher
unmöglich eine einzige proposition aale
einstellung zu haben heißt eine
weitgehend korrekte logik zu haben dh
ein logisch kohärentes muster von
überzeugungen zu haben dies ist ein
grund warum proportionale einstellung zu
haben heißt ein rationales geschäft zu
sein
dieser punkt betrifft auch intentional
handlungen also gerichtete handlung ein
intensiver alle handlung ist eine
handlung die in bezug auf überzeugungen
wünsche erklärt werden kann
deren position aale gehalte die handlung
rationalen machen
in ähnlicher weise muss eine emotion wie
froh zu sein mit dem rauchen aufgehört
zu haben eine emotions sein team
lichtete eigenen überzeugungen und werte
rational ist jetzt haben sie gesehen
jetzt kommt hier die verbindung zum
rationalität thema jetzt hier kommt
jetzt rationalität spiel
ok gedanken haben genau wie proposition
logische relation also die solis muss
wieder zog mit anderen ab von anderen ab
hier hatten wir noch mal sehr schön der
die identität eines gedankens nicht von
seinem platz in einem logischen netz
andere gedanken geschieden werden kann
lässt er sich in diesem netz nicht
anderswohin setzen ohnehin versetzen
müsste man nur sagen ohne dass ein
anderer gedanke wird das ist der roll is
muss jetzt auf die spitze getrieben das
ist also ein gedanke wirklich immer nur
in einem ganz spezifischen kontext ist
dieser gedanke dieser gedanke wir können
gedanken nicht isoliert denken sagt
unabhängig von überzeugungen von anderen
positionen
das ist diese in faenza listige
grundgedanke von vom gedanken
eine einzige professionelle einstellung
zu haben heißt eine weitgehend korrekte
logik zu haben das heißt ein logisch
corinth es musste von überzeugungen zu
haben
als um überhaupt eine position voll
formen zu können muss ich schon kohärenz
voraussetzen können opposition position
könnte man auch sagen ist eine art
schluss zuständig sie jetzt vor so eine
art schlussfolgerung also beste
erklärung und in dem sie so eine art
schluss charakter hat hat sie auf jeden
fall eine kohärenz ich komme zu dieser
profession weil die anderen
rahmenbedingungen so sind dass sie sie
nahe legen und dadurch habe ich durch
die proposition allein schon eine
kohärenz und das wiederum würde nach
davidson dazu führen zu sagen dass wir
durch die korrelation von einem
rationalen geschöpft ausgehen können
internationale handlung würde eher sagen
genauso indem ich auf etwas gerichtet
bin zeigt das dass ich stützen die
gründe habe die mich in dieser richtung
bestärken also gerichtet zu sein wäre
nach davidson schon irgendwie
hinreichend dafür eine form von
rationalität zu haben das ist jetzt
natürlich ein ziemlich starker blicke
von internationalität etwas zu verfolgen
heißt für ihn irgendwie auch gründe zu
haben
dieses bestimmte dinge oder was auch
immer zu verfolgen das heißt ich muss da
schon ganz schön rational zuganges sein
und das kann man jetzt in frage stellen
ob internationalität wirklich so zum
stark gefasst werden muss er fast ist
sehr stark auf er hat einen sehr starken
begriffs begriff wenn ich es recht zäh
und das scheint in ihren auf dieser
seite von die karte zu bringen ohne dass
jetzt hier wie sie bestimmt merken
irgendwie subjektivität eine rolle
spielt davidson argumentiert ohne
referenz auf subjektivität oder
bewusstsein und selbstbewusstsein
diese ganzen sachen von der karte fallen
völlig weg also was müssen wir dann hier
hinschreiben nach davidson was die
einheit des bewusstseins setzt welche
einheit hat jetzt hier davidson statt
der einheit des bewusstseins würden sie
sagen
[Musik]
ja
ja die einheit des begriffs oder so was
genau realistisch
ganz genau genau richtig genau es sagte
unten in ähnlicher weise muss eine
emotion wie froh zu sein mit dem rauchen
aufgehört sein emotionen zeigen nämlich
der eigenen überzeugung wäre rational
ist also es wäre damit auch seine
position
ich empfinde das aber das wäre dann nach
davids nicht mehr deswegen rational weil
es unter der einheit ist es steht sein
weil es eben im kontext von
überzeugungen und werten steht die
dieser emotion einen sinn geben wieder
diese holistische kontext irgendwie
evozieren
das fragt davidson jedenfalls hier nicht
gute frage
dass sie den hier nicht alles ist
ziemlich subjektivität neutral oder so
natürlich kann uns kann man sich immer
fragen eine überzeugung ist immer die
überzeugung von einem subjekt das ist
damit impliziert irgendwie aber für die
geltung also jetzt verdient gehalt das
argument spielt die tatsache dass jede
überzeugung überzeugung eines subjekt
sein muss die mir scheint keine rolle
also die einheit oder die kohärenz die
verletzten ja die rationalität ist
bekommt hier nach davidson zustand in
dem es um logische oder logische
folgerung beziehung geht und nicht um
die einheit durch das objekt also was
bei descartes dieses ich denke ist was
alles eins scheint mir bei davidson die
kohärenz die logische kohärenz die
zahlen der begriffe
nachdem
die kannten die kann für davidson aus
irgendwas kommen die kann aus dem
subjekt kommen aber für die geld und die
genese spielt für die geltung nach ihm
keine rolle
also die geltung das eben das ganze
rational ist jetzt unabhängig davon ob
es jetzt von mir als subjekt kommt das
interessiert ihn einfach nicht natürlich
kommt zu mehr als objekt aber es spielt
keine rolle weil das entscheide nicht
das subjektive ist sondern dass kurrent
die corinths ist die folgerung beziehung
als er hatte es sehr sprach
philosophische holistische der
formulierung des kt sischen gedankens
wii erscheinen
damit soll die existenz von irrationalen
überzeugung handlungen emotion nicht
bestritten werden dass versteht sich von
selbst eine handlung zu deren ausführung
man gründe hat man gerne hand sein zu
deren vermeidung man bessere kunde hat
eine überzeugung magen lichter einige
aber nicht alle anderen eigene
überzeugung vernünftig sein usw
die entscheidende punkt ist dass die
möglichkeit von einer irrationalität zu
einem hohen grad von rationalität
abhängt irrationalität ist nicht einfach
ein mangel an vernunft sind eine
krankheit oder eine störung der vernunft
oder das ist jetzt spannend aha
kann
das finde ich jetzt sehr spannend hier
also ich glaube dass du dein punkt für
sich hat als nationalität ist eben
nichts was mit wenig fünfter tun hat
sondern ihre nationalität kann gerade
auch auf einem hohen vernunft niveau das
fitness seien mangels dann eben
irgendwie ja ich werde auch nicht ganz
schlau ist dieser metapher jetzt der
krankheit der vernunft also was mir sehr
eindeutig ist es sagen irrationalität
muss jetzt nicht bedeutet dass da zu
wenig vernunft im spiel war
rationalität kann bedeuten die vernunft
im spiel war
die wurde nicht richtig gebraucht die
wurde nicht richtig eingesetzt
aber bedeutet das nicht dann zu sagen
die fernzüge nicht richtig eingesetzt
heißt es da nicht das ist ein mangel an
vernunft war also mir ist einfach nicht
klar was jetzt genau unter dieser
metapher der krankheit und der störung
zu verstehen ist
der in die welt hinaus
möchtest du aufpassen dass wieder
nachlesen
immer produktiven
da ist es nicht
danke
wir können wir auch einmal
wichtig auch irrationale handlung
geschehen aus überzeugung heraus
letztendlich würden sie sagen also es
gibt immer auch gründe für ihr
rationales handeln werden und insofern
auch für rationales handeln gründe da
sind ist es nicht ein mangel an vernunft
inhalt eine störung
würde würde eben jetzt david zu sagen
ich glaube auch dass es sein argument
stützt das wird doch er fand ihren
unterschieden sind jetzt haben wir
mehrere meldungen erst sieht ansehen und
dann sie ja
ja also ästhetische produkten wie
ästhetische produkten der rationalität
haben gut
ja ja die frage ist halt ob sich
kunstprodukte dann noch gleichsetzen das
mit begrifflichen sachen also kunst
begrifflich ist dann ist die frage ob
kunst nicht eher assoziativ ist also ob
ja
dann wäre es ja richtig
dann wäre es ein klassischer fall von
rationalität würde sagen ein gedicht und
kunstwerke formuliert bei dem ist es
ganz ähnlich einsatz so eine position
ein gedicht oder irgendwie ein
sachverhalt der dort halbwegs
begrifflich dargestellt wird der kann
und im gedicht noch viel weniger nicht
ohne eine aura existieren als ein
gedicht hat eben auch begrifflich oder
ästhetisch oder wird immer eine ganz
ganz starke aura sogar bei gedicht hier
noch viel mehr von kohärenz leben weil
sie ja so wenig gehalt haben weil sie so
abstrakt sind
wir müssen halt sagen gedichte sind
dennoch holistisch mit bedeutung
ich denke es ging dann um bedeutung
gedichte haben eine aura von
konnotationen von bedeutungen die damit
schwingen
denke ich schon also die frage ist wie
gesagt was ist jetzt jedes kriterium für
rationalität sowie ein wenig recht lese
wenn ich es recht verstehe
nach dem letzten zitat geht es ihm
einfach um eine rein logisch kohärentes
muster ein logo ein netz es geht um am
netz und ein logisch corrientes muster
nicht mal unbedingt überzeugen sondern
nur ein
dann muss man logisch klingt es musste
jetzt hatten sie sich
abdrücken
und vielleicht
das
ja als er würde dann bestimmt sagen wenn
wir jetzt mal verteidigen wollen es muss
nicht logisch sein aber es muss corinne
zahlen und ich denke kunst ist durchaus
corinth also ein kunstwerk hat immer
eine gewisse harmonie
auch wenn es ein buch von harmonie ist
da ist immer eine kohärenz dahinter
würde ich schon sagen dass kunst durch
karenz erklärt werden kann
ja richtig das ist die kohärenz die
kohärenz die kohärenz der inkohärenz
sozusagen als es wieder korrekt
waren diese genau als er will wirklich
sagen auch falsch überzeugung oder
schlechtere gründe sind auch immer noch
irgendwie zeichen von vernunft tätigkeit
hier sehen wir haben es hier mit einem
sehr interessanten text zu tun
wir werden jetzt wieder nicht ganz durch
kommen
ich bete mal ein bisschen vor
ich gehe mal ganz zum ende hin gelesen
aber das nächste mal noch mal weiter
ich gehe jetzt mal ganz ans ende ich bin
nach den letzten
ich bin ganz am ende des textes
ich glaube ich
das ist zur fast am ende also ich lese
mal hier beginnt mit
was würde eine beherrschung dieses
gegensatzes zeigen offensichtlich genug
sprachliche kommunikation um die rede
eines anderen zu verstehen muss ich
fähig seien dieselben dinge zu denken an
die er denkt ich muss seine welt teilen
ich muss nicht in allen punkten
übereinstimmen aber um ein uneins zu
sein müssen wir über die gleichen
position verfügen über den gleichen
gegenstand bereich und im gleichen
wahrheit' begriff kommunikation hängt
davon ab dass jeder
kommunikationspartner inbegriff von
einer geteilten welt für eine
interaktive welt hat und korrekter weise
auch denkt dass der anderen ebenfalls
hat aber der begriff von einer
intuitiven welt ist der begriff von
einer objektiven welt von einer welt von
der jeder kommunikationspartner
überzeugungen haben kann okay es war
weiter ich schlage somit vor dass der
begriff für inter subjektive wahrheit
als grundlage für überzeugung und damit
auch für gedanken im allgemeinen genügt
und vielleicht ist es plausibel genug
dass das verfügen über den begriffen in
der subjektive wahrheit von
kommunikation im vollen sprachlichen
sinn abhängig ist und die argumentation
abzuschließen muss sich aber noch zeigen
dass der einzige weg auf dem man zum
kontrast überzeugung wahrheit gelangen
kann dazu darüber führt der begriff von
inter subjektive wahrheit zu haben
ich gestehe dass ich nicht weiß wie ich
dies zeigen könnte aber ich habe auch
keine ahnung wie man sonst zum begriff
von einer objektiven wahrheit gelangen
könnte anstelle eines arguments ersten
schritt biete ich folgende analogie an
dann geht es noch mal weiter und jetzt
sagt er hier ganz am ende also die
schlussfolgerung aus diesen
betrachtungen lautet das rationalität
ein soziales merkmal ist nur
kommunikationspartner haben sie das ist
jetzt die höchste mal noch ein bisschen
genauer betrachten wollen die frage ist
jetzt natürlich die sind tiere nicht
auch kommunikationspartner das ist jetzt
die frage können tiere nicht auch
kommunizieren
daran hängt jetzt offensichtlich an
diesem sozialer und das wollen wir uns
jetzt nochmal aufs nächste mal fragen
die mir den text zu ende lesen also
reserviert jetzt davidson diese
kommunikation nur für menschliche
lebensform oder games nicht die
möglichkeit dass tiere nach seinem
verständnis
mit diesem wahrheit' begriff mit dieser
geteilten welt auch kommunizieren
das soll die frage bis zum nächsten mal
seien dann bis zur nächsten sitzung